hi there welcome to today's session
we're going to talk about aws here by
the way i'm sam
i work as an cloud architect and
technical author with simply learn
in this section we're going to talk
about what is cloud computing
and how things were before aws and we're
going to talk about
what is aws and the benefits of aws
and the products and services that
amazon offers as of now
and then finally we're going to end the
session with a project
that is going to help us understand how
to create
a jenkins build server for continuous
integration
and in this project we will learn about
how to deploy
and host jenkins and open source
automation software
predominantly used for cicd otherwise
continuous integration and continuous
development
so what is cloud computing cloud
computing is the on-demand
delivery of computer sources through a
cloud platform
accessed via the internet and it is a
it's also a pay as
you go service be it compute capacity or
database or storage
in cloud we access them through the
internet and that too
on a pay-as-you-go pricing model let's
talk about how things were
before aws existed expedia as we know as
the people
logistic company or the company that
helps people move
around the world with ease has a certain
problem before they decided to migrate
to aws
and migrating to aws was a solution to
their problem
back then booking ticket was an
unpleasant experience compared
to what it is now it generally would
take a long time
to book a ticket and sometimes it would
time out if there is a promotion or if
a huge sale announced and if the
environment is
not scaled up to meet the demand and
sometimes it would time out if there is
a promotion or if a
huge sale announced and they could not
scale up the environment and
keep up with the speed after promotion
that's when they got introduced to aws
and with the aws power to increase the
capacity of the
environment on the fly solved their
scaling issue
instead of waiting on the new hardware
to arrive and wondering what to do with
the hardware when the promotion is
over with aws we can quickly scale up
the environment when there is a need
and scale down the environment during
lull periods now that being said
let's talk about what is aws amazon web
services
or in short aws is a secure cloud
service platform offering compute power
database content delivery and other
functionality that
you would need to help your business
scale and grow
aws is a very secure cloud platform and
such security cannot be imagined
in on premises without spending a
fortune almost any type of applications
can be created and deployed in the cloud
which
includes the latest iot applications
machine learning
artificial intelligence and so on and
the best part is
we can avail this service from anywhere
as long as we have an active internet
and all this is availed on pay as you go
subscription
now let's talk about the benefits of aws
aws cloud platform is
very easy to use one needs no
complicated programming
or compute knowledge to access and use
this environment
even with less programming and compute
knowledge one could become
a probe in accessing and maintaining the
cloud the products and services offered
are very flexible in nature
and that provides room for us to easily
integrate the service to other services
in aws
and services outside aws cloud in
general
is a very reliable service and aws in
specific is very reliable
cloud in general is very reliable and
when we talk about
aws it's very true a statistic says that
about
95 percent of the cloud computing in the
whole world
is run on aws due to aws reliable nature
their services in aws are scalable by
nature and most of the services provide
click button scaling
services in aws are very cost effective
and it becomes very true when you start
using
more services and aws are very cost
effective
and it becomes very true when you start
using more
service services and aws are very cost
effective
and it becomes more true when we start
using more
since when we start using more service
the per unit price
drops down even further security in the
cloud is at its highest
with encryption and multi-factor
authentications
and being able to audit the logs one can
be sure that when one hosts a service in
aws they are hosting it in an
environment which has been built with
enterprise security in mind all right
let's now talk about
or talk briefly about the different
products and services available in the
cloud
some of the products and services
available in the cloud are compute
storage database migration services
networking and content delivery
developer tools and services available
for managing
the aws environment tools needed for
machine learning development
analytic tools needed for security and
identity compliance tools needed for
mobile application services tools needed
for
iot and gaming development are some of
the products that are available in aws
all right let's first talk about compute
service
now compute service it enables us to
develop ly
run and scale our applications and
workloads on the cloud
you might agree with me that compute
service is the fundamental
of any applications and aws provides
many options to use those compute
services in the cloud starting from
ec2 which is a vm in the cloud to lambda
which is server less computing in the
cloud to compute service
compute service also includes container
services and services that help
batch processing and deploying
applications and load balancing the
request when we run our applications on
multiple servers and services that help
batch processing
and developing applications and load
balancing the request
when we run our applications in multiple
servers
we're going to talk about two compute
products in specific
let's talk about ec2 ec2 is a service
with a resizable compute capacity in the
cloud that allows
business subscribers to run application
programs in the computing environment
and the best part here is ec2 is
resizable
anytime there is more demand i can
simply resize my computer
to meet the demand on the other hand
lambda is a serverless compute service
used to execute backend codes it really
helps us to focus on the core
competencies like application
building the code let's talk about
storage service for a while aws storage
is known for its durability and
availability
with s3 being the object storage for the
internet where users or application can
directly upload and download the content
from the internet
and ebs being a durable block storage
that gets attached to the ec2 instance
and glacier being the archival solution
in the cloud and storage gateway being
the gateway for storing data locally and
having a backup in the cloud in case of
disaster
let's talk about two important storage
service products
in the cloud which is s3 now s3 is an
web based cloud storage service it's
designed for
online backup and archiving of data and
the best part
about s3 is that it provides 11.9
durability which means once we stored
the data in s3 the chances
of losing the data is nearly zero ebs on
the other hand
provides persistent and resizable and
migratable storage to the vms or
ec2s that we can run in the cloud now
let's talk about the database offerings
in the cloud
beginning with rds for sql and dynamodb
for nosql
and elastic cache for web caching
services and amazon
redshift for petabyte scale data
warehousing services
aws database service provides all the
database service
needs we might have let's talk about two
database
services in specific rds rds is an
web service that is designed to simplify
the setup
operation and scaling of the relational
database in the cloud
and dynamodb is an fast and flexible
nosql database service which is well
known for its low latency and
scalability performance
network and content delivery service
contributes to the
infrastructure as a service side of the
cloud it provides a secure cloud
infrastructure and connects our physical
network
to our private virtual network with low
latency
and high transfer speeds and under
networking and content delivery services
vpc is virtual private cloud networking
in the cloud
route 53 is the dns service in the cloud
and direct connect is a service that
connects
our on-premises with aws environment
through point-to-point
cables and cloud front is content
delivery network or
caching servers throughout the world
let's talk about vpc for a while vpc
it enables us to launch aws resources
into a virtual network
that we define in the cloud vpc
resembles very similar to our office
network
with the subnets firewalls private zones
public or dmz zones and lot more we can
also
create a vpn connection between
on-premises and cloud environment
through this vpc and route 53 it is a
scalable
and highly available domain name system
web service that
helps to route the end users to the
internet application now aws is a domain
registrar as well
and here we can buy domain names for our
organization
and use them to mask the ip addresses
behind it
and by the way if you didn't know
already dns is the one that translates
human readable names like www.xyz.com
into the numeric ip address let's talk
about developer tool services now
developer tool services in amazon
provides
services where developers can store an
application source code and
automatically build
test and deploy applications on aws out
of which
aws codestar enables us to quickly
develop
build and deploy applications in aws
and code build is a fully managed build
service
that compiles source code runs test
and produces software packages that are
ready
to deploy and code deploy on the other
hand is a service that automatic that
automates
is a service that automates software
developments to a variety of
compute services including amazon ec2
amazon lambda and even instances running
on premises
and aws code pipeline is a continuous
integration and continuous
delivery service for fast and reliable
application and infrastructure updates
let's talk about codestar codestar is a
service designed for developers
where they can quickly deploy build and
develop
applications on aws aws codestar
provides
a unified user interface enabling us to
easily manage
our software development activities in
one place with aws codestar
we can set up our entire continuous
delivery tool chain in minutes
allowing us to start releasing codes
faster
and not only that aws codestar makes it
easy for
you or your whole team to work together
securely
allowing you to easily manage access and
add owners contributors and
viewers to our project and not only that
aws codestar project comes with a
project management dashboard
including an integrated issue tracking
capabilities provided by
jira software with the aws code star
project dashboard we can easily track
progress across
our entire software development process
from our
backlog of work items to teams recent
code deployments so on and so forth aws
code build on the other hand
is an cloud service that enables an it
developer
to build and test code with continuous
scaling now here
you pay only for the build time that you
have used with aws code build
we there is no need for us to provision
manage
and scale our own build servers code
build scales continuously
and process and processes multiple bills
concurrently
so our bills are not left waiting in the
queue because it's processed
concurrently
let's talk about security identity and
complaint services
available in amazon in general the
security identity and complaint services
in amazon helps us
to maintain a secure environment in
amazon
by providing services for user
authentication
for limiting the access to certain set
of users
on the aws environment out of which iam
or identity and access management it's a
product that enables us to manage
access to aws services and resources
that enables us to manage
access to aws resources and services in
a secure fashion
using iam we can create and manage aws
users
and groups and use permissions to allow
and deny their access to aws resources
on the other hand kms or key management
service
is a managed service that makes it easy
for us to create and control
the encryption keys used to encrypt our
data
and cognito it lets us to add user sign
up sign in and access control to our web
and mobile apps
quickly and easily and waff or web
application firewall
helps us to protect our web applications
from common
web exploits that could affect
application availability that could
compromise security or consume
excessive resources and uh it gives us
good control over which traffic to allow
or block to our applications by sort of
defining
customizable web security rules we can
use
waft to create custom rules that block
common attack patterns
such as sql injections or cross
cross-site
scripting and we can also create rules
that are designed for our specific
application
out of all the four identity and access
management
it helps us to control access to aws
services and resources
for our users with the identity and
access management i can
restrict user access or i can give a
user complete access
to the environment if it's an admin i
can assign complete access and if it is
a user i can
provide some privileged access or less
or
degraded or no access depending on the
role that the user plays
in the organization and kms is a service
that helps us to create
and control the encryption keys used to
encrypt the data and also
we can use hardware security model hsm
to protect the security of our data in
the cloud
also we can use hardware security model
to protect the security
of the key itself and let's talk about
the management the tools and services
available in amazon
management tools and services it helps
us to
manage monitor and automate all the
resources running in the aws
infrastructure
beginning with the cloud watch a service
which monitors the environment by
receiving
logs and creating a dashboard and
sending alerts as needed and cloud
formation a service that
a service through which we can deploy
new environments
using just templates and auto scaling a
product that lets us to handle the
dynamic traffic with ease
by dynamically scaling up and scaling
down the environment as needed and
cloudtrail is another product or another
monitoring tool
that helps us to monitor or collect the
logs
of all the api calls to our environment
and provides a searchable
tool based on keywords and timestamps
let's talk about cloudwatch a bit more
detail
now cloudwatch is a monitoring service
for aws with cloudwatch we can collect
we can
track the metrics we can collect and
monitor log files we can also
enable cloudwatch to set alarms and
automatically react to changes
in the aws environment cloudwatch can
also monitor aws resources
such as ec2 instances dynamodb tables
amazon rds instances as well as custom
metrics
generated by your application and
services and any log
files your applications would generate
now we can use cloudwatch to get a
system-wide visibility
into resource utilization application
performance and
operational health we can use these
insights to react
and keep your applications running
smoothly and cloud formation on the
other hand
provides a common language for us to
describe and provision
all the infrastructure resources in our
cloud environment now cloud formation
allows us to set up and model all our
aws resources so that we can spend less
time in managing those resources and
more time
on our application our cloud formation
is really an
infrastructure as a code service where i
can build an
infrastructure based on the portable
template i might be carrying
all right in this demo session we'll
talk about how to install
jenkins on amazon linux ec2 instance and
before that
let's talk about what is jenkins and
what is the purpose of
it why it is used and all that stuff now
what is jenkins now jenkins is an
open source automation server and it
provides a lot of
inbuilt plugins for deploying and
automating any project
in short you know it's an continuous
integration server and it is used for
many purposes
used for tasks that take care of
continuous deployment
and delivery and it provides these
advantages like the developer now will
not have to focus
on fixing errors because errors are
automatically handled by
jenkins and because of that it leads to
faster
development environment all right so how
do we go about doing it let's get
started the first thing is to
go to our console and uh launch an ec2
instance
actually let me walk you through the
steps through the ppt
and then i'll show it in the console so
let me first walk you through the steps
in
installing a jenkins server in this lab
we're going to launch an
vm or a virtual application server to
host our jenkins installation and then
we are going to deploy jenkins on top of
it and then
configure it as an build server and for
this
we will need an aws account to begin
with and then a bit of experience in
jenkins and then some familiarity on ec2
and how ec2 gets connected to vpc stuff
like that so when we're all done
this is how the architect is going to
look like you know users they get
connected to ec2 instance
which is a jenkins server and then there
are slaves
build slaves that can be monitored that
can be
used in deployment by the jenkins server
so let's see how it is done
all right so let's first launch a server
let it be an
amazon linux instance i'm going to pick
t2 micro
because of the free eligibility and
because this is a lab
that should be more than enough and i'm
going to keep this as default you know
i'm going to stick with the default vpc
and i'm going to keep all the settings
as defaults and then i'm not going to
add a storage i'm going to keep the
storage limited with the root volume and
then for
security group because we're going to
access it through the internet
i would like port 80 in fact since this
is a lab environment and since
i'll be tearing it down all right after
the lap is over
we're going to use all ip or we're going
to use anywhere all traffic
anywhere view and launch and i
already have a key pair that i have
created if you're not familiar with
creating keypair launching ec2 instance
you might need to spend some time
watching the aws ec2 video that would
help so i already have a key pair
that's attached to this account in this
region so i'm using that key pair
to launch the instance
all right then that's my jenkins server
all right so once that is installed
let's log into it since this being an
linux instance i'm going to use putty to
log in and then use the key pair
that we have downloaded to log in and
the key pair was
right here
all right now i'm connected to it as
first thing we will have to install
the java environment i'm going to show
some commands towards
end so if you're planning to do labs
yourself you can use those commands
they will be very handy in fact i can
show it right now as we speak
so these commands are to install java
environment
and it has two versions as we speak and
i've chosen the latest version so i've
typed two and i've chosen the latest
version in installing java environment
the second
is to install apache maven let me show
you some commands
that's used to install apache mavic and
these commands vary from you know linux
version to linux version so if you're
using
a different linux version just be sure
that you're using commands which are
respective to that particular version
all right let's
install apache maven
looks like some of them are already
installed and
it's doing error for some but anyway
it's an it's considered unsuccessful
installation and then
let's install jenkins
and the commands to install jenkins is
right here
so these are to install jenkins and i
mean to download
the software and install it and then
start
the jenkins and make sure the jenkins
stays
running even after a reboot so let's run
these commands
all right now jenkins should be ready or
the jenkins server is installed
in our ac2 instance and it is ready for
us to access
and the default port is port 8080
so let me go to the url or
ip let me go to that and then try
accessing it
using port 8080
there you go so at the moment it's
locked it requires admin password
to log in and the admin password is
present
in this particular folder and this
particular file
in the linux instance so let me get that
okay one moment looks like the admin
password is not present just give me one
quick moment
okay it's just a permission issue let me
check the password in that folder again
with the elevated
permissions there you go there's my
password
all right once we're logged in we can
install all the suggested plugins
now that's going to take some time to
run and install all the selected
all the default logins needed to run a
jenkins server
all right it's done now as next thing
it's going to ask for
the admin username and password you can
choose as an existing administrator or
you can also create
an another admin user in this case i'm
going to create another admin user
alright so the jenkins server is
installed we can use the
similar but slightly different procedure
on the jenkins nodes
or the slave servers to make them
jenkins slave and
respond to the bills that we push or
receive the bills or receive the jobs
that we push through this jenkins server
so we have built this
jenkins server on amazon ac2 a similar
and slightly different procedures can be
followed to build
jenkins build servers that can contact
jenkins server to receive jobs and you
know start working
thank you for watching i believe you
enjoyed the session i'll meet you in
another session thank you
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here